Let's take a quick example. Suppose the message forma is as follows. Y, d and x,
where x is the origin of the message. Y is the node being claimed as root and do
is the distance of the particular node sending
this message, x from a claimed root. So, initially
every switch in the network broadcast a message
like x,0,x to indicate that the node that it
think itself is the root. When other switches hear
this method, they compare the ID of the sender to
their owner ID, and they update their opinion of who
the root is based on the comparison of these IDs.
Let's suppose that we have the following graph and
switch number 4 thinks it's the root. So we will
send a message 4, 0, 4 to nodes 2 and 7. But 2 also thinks it is the root, so.
4 is going to receive the message 2, 0, 2
from node 2, and then it's going to realize that
4 is just one hop away from node 2. So
node 4 will update its view of the root to
be node 2, eventually 4 will also hear a
message 2, 1, 7 from node 7; indicating that node
7 thinks it is one hop away. From its view
of the root, which is node 2. It will realize
that the path through node 7 is a longer
path to the root, and it will remove the link
4, 7 from the tree. We can repeat this process
and ultimately we will end up with a spanning tree.